und in berlin begrüße ich jetzt mit
lennart ich an oskar
guten abend fraud ich an oskar guten
abend
sie haben in den letzten wochen mehrere
politiker getroffen um über die
angespannte lage in ihrer heimat belarus
zu berichten
sie waren im eu-parlament trafen
frankreichs präsident marco und heute
die bundeskanzlerin
was erhoffen sie sich von angela merkel
wie kann sie ihnen helfen
zunächst möchte ich sagen dass sich
deutschland unter bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel sehr dankbar für diesen besuch
wir fühlen uns durch ihre einladung sehr
geehrt und es war für mich persönlich
eine besondere ehre als vertreterin des
volks von belarus mit ihr sprechen zu
dürfen
wir sehen die bundeskanzlerin frau
merkel als eine der mächtigsten ihn
führungspersönlichkeiten der welt an
und ich bin mir sicher dass sie uns bei
unserer politischen krise in belarus
helfen kann
wir haben die bundeskanzlerin in der tat
gebeten eine vermittlerrolle für die
aufnahme eines dialogs zwischen den
behörden und dem belarussischen volk in
unserem land zu übernehmen
sie hoffen also auf unterstützung von
seiten deutschlands aber auch der eu
letzte woche hat die eu nach langem hin
und her sanktionen gegen mehrere
unterstützer lukaschenko sanktionen
erlassen alexander lukaschenko selbst
blieb jedoch außen vor
wünschen sie sich mehr engagement von
seiten der eu also diese sanktionen sind
unser erster sieg
die liste ist unserer meinung nach sehr
kurz wir sind sicher dass die liste der
sanktionierten personen erweitert werden
sollte und herr lukaschenkos name muss
auch auf der liste stehen
seit mehr als zwei monaten dauern die
massenproteste gegen lukas schenkel nun
schon an
jede woche werden demonstranten
festgenommen und verprügelt und lukas
schenkel sitzt aber weiterhin fest im
sattel
die prominentesten gesichter der
opposition sind entweder in haft oder im
ausland befindet sich ihre bewegungen
der sackgasse wird ein esel was ich weiß
ist dass sich die meinung des billa
russischen volk nicht ändern wird
unsere demonstration unser protest
werden weitergehen bis zum beginn eines
dialogs bis zu unserem sieg bis es
neuwahlen geben wird
das volk von belarus ist aufgewacht und
es wird nicht in den zustand
zurückkehren können indem es 26 jahre
lang gelebt hat wir werden weitermachen
was macht sie da so sicher woher kommen
diese kraft für den wandel
meine persönliche stärke kommt vom von
belarus denn ich sehe wie die mehrheit
des volkes in meinem land diese
veränderung will wir brauchen diese
veränderung auch für mich persönlich ist
es einfach notwendig dass meine kinder
in einem sicheren und freien land leben
ich will nicht dass meine kinder die
sklaven dieses regimes sind
jeder geht aus eigenen persönlichen
gründen zu den demonstrationen
die menschen kämpfen für ihre eigene
zukunft für die zukunft ihrer kinder und
wir sind jetzt vereint wie nie zuvor
nachdem sie nach litauen geflüchtet sind
hat ihre mitstreiterin maria kohl s
nikkor war in belarus die stellung
gehalten seit einem monat befindet sie
sich jetzt in u-haft haben sie kontakt
zu ihr wissen sie wie es ihr geht
hier wir haben über ihren anwalt von ihr
gehört
sie schickt jedes mal grüße und das
ganze belarussische volk und auch an uns
persönlich geht ihr gut soweit man das
von jemand sagen kann ein gefängnis ist
und sie ist eine äusserst tapfere frau
und sie hat ihren roten lippenstift
ich danke ihnen